still think you'd be better off with Tom
let's go
both of us fans do
we're all dying to see it this the
series adapted for
selling video game is a ratings
Juggernaut for HBO and when the audience
is in the millions you're bound to have
some eagle-eyed fans like the ones who
spotted this moment in episode 6.
no it wasn't a clicker check out the
bottom left I think it works pretty well
I think they planned it actually this
looks pretty unplanned some crew members
sticking out in post-apocalyptic Wyoming
this is the next level of really getting
into something by ex like an immersive
experience of playing these characters
um and so people's relationship to that
experience is a deep one a hit HD series
with an eye-catching editing mistake
sound familiar well as how Stark would
say
tell them the north remembers Game of
Thrones fans will never forget the
accidental Starbucks cup that made it
into this scene from The Final Season do
you watch Game of Thrones I do not I
love Starbucks coffee though I think it
was a pumpkin spice who's at fault for
coffee cup gate well on The Tonight Show
the cast pointed fingers I'm gonna just
go with I mean look who it's placed in
front whoa
Amelia conlis okay he plays Varys who's
sitting next to me in that scene uh he
pulls me aside and he's like me like
I'll tell you something I gotta tell you
something love
um The Coffee Cup was mine another
suspect ironically The Last of Us star
Bella Ramsey we named you King in the
north and get this Bella's co-star Pedro
Pascal is another Westeros veteran but
only Bell is connected to both now
Infamous TV moments and this is a
spoiler for a couple of episodes ago
this girl dies this is a scene from the
episode after she dies so why am I
holding this coffee cup
that's in a different scene but we that
was like an inspiration that was a thing
we talked about it because I watched the
show before I got the job and I
continued watching it after I got it so
I got to meet and fall in love with Lady
Mormont in the way that everyone else
did
of course on-screen oversights can't
stop HBO's latest phenomenon it's
renewed for season two which is set to
adapt the video games 2020 sequel
it ends the way it ends
there's Parts in the video game that
work amazing in the video game part but
just when you become like um to a more
passive medium like TV they want to work
so that's where we're like oh let's
let's do something different and I think
that for me that's been part of the fun
of like expanding the world beyond what
we did in the game I Love Game of
Thrones they had so many more books and
things and so much story to tell because
George writes these very long and
incredible involved novels for me and
for meal we're like you know what let's
I think we cover what's there you know I
think the nice thing is that the next
storyline is quite more involved it's
longer so we we would be able to come
and do more than another season but
first we have to you know people have to
watch it well be careful what you wish
for
[Music]